Okay.
I think folks are going to like this follow
up on the Gavin McInnes situation.
So Gavin McInnes is
formerly one of the are, he is one of the
founders of vice.
He hasn't been involved with vice for a very
long time.
He was one of the cofounders of the proud
boys, although I am told he has since distanced
himself from that extremist group.
Uh, in any case, the newest thing he's doing
is he has a new show and I was invited onto
that program.
I told you last week how, uh, I was offered,
um, a whole bunch of money to be on that program.
Others have reported, uh, including Sam Cedar
being offered $5,000 to appear on Gavin McInnes
program, which is a pay walled program, meaning
you only can see the content if you become
a paid subscriber.
Uh, my manager actually did some negotiation
with the Gavin McInnes team, which may have
been actually just Gavin McInnes communicating
with my manager under a different name and
was able to actually negotiate, um, uh, a
pretty substantial rate.
And in the midst of this negotiation that
was going on, I received a phone call from
a guy named Jim telling me that I should appear
on Gavin McInnes his show who we later determined
with like 99.9% certainty was actually Gavin
McInnes himself.
Here's a reminder about that.
Okay, let's go next to our caller from the
two five, three area code.
Who's calling today from two five three.
Hey David, it's a gym and I just wanted to
say a longtime listener.
First time caller.
Love Ya.
And I just wanted to talk about the green
new deal and just see what ideas you had about
maybe getting that pushed through.
And also I'm a guy I despise up on my youtube
the other day on a commercial Gavin McInnes
on this new show free speech.
And I was trying to click out of it right
away and then all of a sudden I saw Dr Cornell
West and Marc Lamont Hill on the show.
Yeah.
And I actually checked it out and um, it's
a cool show in regards to just liberals, uh,
nailing, uh, Gavin.
And it was so awesome to watch, especially
Marc Lamont Hill.
I canceled my subscription because I saw all
the shows, but I just thought it'd be awesome
if you could get on his show and destroy him.
So hold on.
You said you canceled your subscription to
what?
Oh, I signed up just to wash the doctor Lamont
Hill.
Oh, I see.
I see.
Cornell slash
the speech.
So then Sam Cedar from the majority report
later did a segment explaining that he also
had been invited to appear on Gavin McInnes
his program.
He also talked about this call I received
from quote Jim, who appears to really have
been Gavin himself.
Uh, Anna Casp, Berrien from the young Turks
was also invited.
She did a segment about it in the last day
or two and uh, covered that as well as a salmon.
I being invited onto the program to appear
with Gavin McInnes and now hilariously, Gavin
himself has done an entire episode attacking
us because despite the offer of money, we
have at least so far refused to appear on
his program, which is hilarious because if
we will only, so if we get invited with no
with no money being on the table and we refuse
to appear, we are not willing to engage with
the other side or whatever.
If we are offered money and appear, then it's,
well, we're only appearing because we were
given money, not because we actually want
to engage with the other side.
If we turn down the appearance despite the
offer of thousands and thousands of dollars
to appear, uh, then all of a sudden the problem
is that we are just not willing to engage
with the other side.
Even though you would think that it would
be a sign of a sort of, uh, the, the, uh,
the, the fact that we are not going to be
tainted or influenced by the money alone.
We are going to actually make decisions about
what appearances do and don't make sense.
So check this out.
This is a tweeted screenshot promoting this
event where Gavin says, this episode, this
entire episode is dedicated to Anna Cas, Berrien,
Sam Cedar, and David Pacman who appeared to
be outraged that Gavin offered the money to
debate a conservative.
Why is it so hard to get liberal guests?
Why do they consistently refuse to compete
in the marketplace of ideas?
And people actually wrote to me and they said,
David, you really should address this.
Like why not just appear and compete in the
marketplace of ideas with Gavin?
What's important for you to understand is
that the pitch was not debate Gavin McInnes
about this topic or that topic or the corrosive
nature of his influence on the political discourse.
The invitation was show up and have Gavin
McInnes play talk show host and moderate a
discussion between David Pakman in some conservative
Sam Cedar in some conservative and a cast
Berrien and some conservative.
And the, the problem I have with this, and
I've talked to Sam about this as well, is
that I feel as though I'm contributing to
the whitewashing of Gavin McInnes in a way
that I was not immediately comfortable with.
And to be clear, I have not actually turned
this down.
The reality is I can't go to New York City
and do this until the fall anyway.
I'm traveling every single week between now
and Labor Day and we have the David Pakman
show, summer vacation coming up for which
I'll be out of the country.
So we basically just tabled it.
He, I guess, interpreted it as I'm turning
down the appearance.
I'm open in principle to appearing on Gavin
McInnes his program.
But what I feel is the real problem here is
that number one, again, by allowing him to
play talk, show host and moderate a discussion
between another conservative and me.
Uh, I'm sort of whitewash ng mcinnis and again
these are videos that would be paywalls just
for his paid audience.
The last thing I want to do is give this guy
paid subscribers by allowing him to promote
an appearance that I did with someone else
that contributes to the white washing of Gavin
McInnes and may actually get people to sign
up and pay for his program.
Now I'm curious.
I haven't, again, because the show is paywalls,
I have no idea what was actually said during
this episode.
I'm curious whether he addresses the fact
that he called into my show pretending to
be a guy named Jim, suggesting that I should
really as a leftist go and appear on Gavin
McInnes his program.
I don't know if somebody has a subscription
to his program.
Maybe they can tell me if that comes up.
My guess is it does not come up.